pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
visibility is down visibility is down w
WK and z d touch station you dare enter
this house
you
[Music]
pilot to Bombardier [ __ ] it's
Monday July 18 and they don't give a
[ __ ] how you feel eating Monday is a
[ __ ] by how you feel they don't they
just exist and either you jump on the
bandwagon are you on your [ __ ] knees
sucking somebody dick in the [ __ ] and
stockroom you understand me
it's Monday grab your [ __ ] balls bow
to your [ __ ] feet scrape the [ __ ]
Kipling's off your [ __ ] and go out
there with nothing but confidence
oh boo Joey you [ __ ] up to the gills
already understand I'm getting emails
about why is Burt fat all that [ __ ] us
and you [ __ ] ball runs not that off
with that [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] yeah and
why is bad fat and Tom who gives a [ __ ]
okay who gives a [ __ ] you got better
things to worry about to be being jack
close and call into that [ __ ] why is
anybody [ __ ] fat cuz I'm like they'd
[ __ ] sorry so enough with that
[ __ ] I got some tremendous reasons for
you tonight the return of the canister
with no label you don't want to know
what the [ __ ] that is
as soon as somebody's wedding cake man
and I still have a little drop
to fire
my eyes are [ __ ] up because I've been
hitting this bike since 6:35 what the
[ __ ] have you done
I've been writin cleaning capitalizes
[ __ ] taking a shower having well
almond milk smoothie they can't stop me
today don't worry cuz I don't give a
[ __ ] jack Testament - you don't give a
[ __ ] either you hire me you don't give a
[ __ ]
this is a beautiful day to be alive the
birds chirp the sun's out the dogs are
[ __ ] barking as usual what he expects
it's [ __ ] what they understand myself
on the paper is [ __ ] fire
was the Spanish people safe way go they
have swagger in their soul you guys
doing all right everything's beautiful
baby my nose is getting better breathing
[ __ ] oxy-gum you can't do yourself a
favor okay the answer has always been
right here I don't mean to [ __ ] em up on
this [ __ ] but the answers right here
called exes know that [ __ ] you can end
up [ __ ] what you know I'm lucky I am
ia [ __ ] dead right now you'll make up
well she chiseled out of my [ __ ]
mouth when I got him living blood and
coke rocks everywhere
anyway what's that got to do with the
process
which is that this is it based looking
for the [ __ ] answer the rocket the
rule ahem
this is it right here rieflin you know
what you did I come on your smoke call
confront of you [ __ ] jerk losses
shoot at won't it be nice I get a lot of
[ __ ] ratings I don't give a [ __ ]
about ratings I do this because dog and
my 50 PS is as good as it gets no drum
nobody get stabbed
or you get to certain nerds with Chinese
food that's the worst thing that could
happen you felt listen to music probably
get shot will get shot play that's a bad
[ __ ] example but uh it's Monday
[ __ ] I'm feeling good I got a
meeting at 10:00 I'm gonna do the [ __ ] I
can't do jujitsu because I can't get
blasting the laws but I can't do [ __ ]
mobility classes do a little leptin get
the [ __ ] walls going then I got a
meeting at 3:00 and then we heard
tremendous podcast at night any [ __ ]
p.m. I posted in New York City tickets
online our problems get him now I added
two extra shows more than the other
years and this floor [ __ ] show us to
pick one I don't hear them September joy
that no tickets I thought your [ __ ]
jaw like I said Joey who gives a [ __ ]
about that it's on the other smoke this
[ __ ] her by Enya
not make smokin reefer in every morning
getting your vision right for the
[ __ ] alien this world just drop the
[ __ ] bananas I'm off a tree
tremendous there that's why I got a
liberal you think you've made up and had
an uncle Joey had a respected who bring
me [ __ ] dick
took down one mother god you know what
get up who [ __ ] family have with you
you with me they want to be without a
[ __ ] family hey you understand me
button this reefer here I wouldn't smoke
with just anybody
this is the [ __ ] heavy duty people
I let this dry the [ __ ] car - the
mega gorilla
it's still taking it out I just smush
them with my [ __ ] finger you
understand just to slope in a hurry look
at that look at that it's nice and dry
if I tell you the name of this you'll
die
there's a sativa hybrid mix that is
[ __ ] a sensation sensation I'm not a
sativa do it keep your jacket or I'll
shove it up your ass but a good [ __ ]
diesel salad these mess with some [ __ ]
oh are you gonna be a [ __ ] truck
you sit there [ __ ] voices like Robin
Williams what is it who call
anybody why do I do this doesn't want to
get you off on the right [ __ ] thing
I don't we get confused and have people
for combining our milk with Joey or I
don't take me under my [ __ ] Li is I
gotta do here I got a pair like with my
body I smoked a little poops and that
gets the [ __ ] wheels emotion from
their breakfast little things around the
house
I was very problematic CIA surveillance
about the [ __ ] times
but everybody wants to have stung yet to
the gills on the Gauley Lord yogurt
should get my antibiotic in seven days I
have a stand he's empty by there's like
a little [ __ ] day and it's all over
tonight you know why cuz you're not take
care yourself if you don't do when you
really eat when you're my age you don't
have all these problems have a four
surgeries of [ __ ] the six seven years
the fat woman my neck and my [ __ ]
knees you need this [ __ ] the case of
patient needs
and as it it's a beautiful [ __ ]
better be alive the rest is up to you
[ __ ] [ __ ] jesus said will
[ __ ] where's Jesus as Jesus is
hanging out with a boat with eight
[ __ ] he's not but I'm telling ya
Isaac Lee you gotta prove I seen in your
eyes looking I live with that [ __ ] I'm a
dick value the magazine only report no
more American by chemical sighs [ __ ] if
I say stop working please
well that's it [ __ ]
go out there do you think or a or
labyrinth or how our sorry I have a
great day uncle Joey see you
[ __ ] tonight 7:30 periscope 8
o'clock YouTube get ready a [ __ ]